you are going to fire Rockets into your
neighboring nation and then you're going
to take your kids and put them in all
the targets for retaliation and you'll
take your Munitions and put them in
churches and stuff like that uh why is
that Israel's fault well you know the
the headquarters of Hamas is in the
basement of a hospital right they
literally put it in the basement of a
hospital what happened to most people on
college campuses
today have no [__] idea what's going
on over there they have no idea of the
history they have no idea that Israel
bends over backwards to try to spare
civilians they even send like knock
bombs we like and they alert people
they're like look there's a building and
we're taking it out so you got a half
hour to clear everyone out of it mhm
nobody else does that well what's
happening right now is Israel is
messaging people in Palestine saying
we're we're going to have to deal with
Hamas you need to leave right right and
Hamas is messaging them saying stay in
place right that's literally what's
happening we have
a
insane bloodthirsty and by the way it's
it's it's not about land it's about
eliminating
Jews anti-semitic it doesn't even do
just
they want all Jews dead and by the way
they don't want Israeli Jews dead they
want all Jews dead it's the most cut and
dried even thing you know there's a lot
of Wars where there's like some gray
area you know what I mean like you you
sort of maybe
Vietnam um maybe Korean the Korean
conflict it's certain Wars where you're
kind of like I get what that guy's doing
but yeah I do those people do have a
right to defend their you know whatever
this ain't that yeah this is just one
person one side is barbarous and
horrible and
bloodthirsty and wants to eliminate a
race of people and the other wants to
live in peace this is as cut and dry as
you can get how does every [__] dumb
[__] on every college campus side with
the wrong side I but I think it's also
important to remember as well Adam is
that most people on either side just
want to live a life of peace and
unfortunately people get caught up in
this stuff you know like most I assume
most people don't just want to be able
to live their life well I I agree with
that yeah but now here's kind of the the
problem I if you said look most people
in this country aren't Ser serial
killers it's just about
18% you go well [__] you can't live
that's not that's unlivable country you
know what I mean so you they do this
thing all the time where they go most
the people in the Middle East yeah but
they tolerate it and they they let it
happen and they vote for it and they
there would be a rebellion if some
version of that started happening here
and an alarmingly high majority of
Muslims are sort of quietly against the
Jews if not you know if if not actively
they'll sort of look the other way and
look the history of of Israel and
Palestine is complicated the thing that
I find interesting is people always say
well you know the Palestinians are
living in an open prison and they can't
get out well the reason they can't get
out is Egypt did what Donald Trump
promised to do which is they built a
wall right to prevent people from Gaza
getting out and uh I don't know if you
saw this but in every country in the
region there was massive protests of
solidarity right when this terrorist
attack happened none of them are taking
any Palestinian refugees who will
naturally want to leave yeah get
away I'm more fascinated with what's
going on on the campus of Stanford and
Berkeley than this this is this has been
going on for thousands of years it's
it's trouble in the Middle East I've
I've heard it since the day after I was
born I get what this is I do not get why
every 19-year-old on campus got their
brainwashed by it and by the way when
you talk to them they go well the the
they literally say that Israel is doing
what Palestine is is doing well you know
uh actually if you abstract at the
biggest level possible here I think it's
uh in an odd way it's an they're
anti-American yes they see Israel is
American prote in this war is American
dog war dog and so anything that them
anything the United States does bad
we're back enemies of America good we're
back to the 17-year-old who just dates
black guys do you like black guys or do
you know your dad hates black guys and
you're just doing you're just doing the
opposite of whatever because all of you
are just so angry and just rebelling I I
say it all the time it's like if you
play with your dog and you get one of
those you know rubber hoop things and
they bite on it and they start pulling
you know they their instinct is just
they they shake their head and they pull
backwards right so you go oh they're
going that direction no no you can spin
around they'll go the other direction
and all directions in between what
they're doing is they're pulling their
instinct is to do the opposite of
whatever your direction is it's not that
oh he loves North it's he loves whatever
it is whatever whichever direction
you're going he's going the other
direction I I also think as well Adam it
comes back to the point of ideology
whereby you download this way of looking
at the world and it's very comforting
because number one you get a tribe and
we're genetically wired to be part of
the tribe and that is very comforting to
us and number two as well is that it
allows you to be lazy so you don't
actually have to go and do the reading
and think for yourself and analyze
actually what is happening
because that involves a lot of work and
number two it's quite uncomfortable
because you're challenging
preconceptions that you have about a
particular issue yes and number three as
well it means that then you then start
to disagree with people because you go
well actually no I know what you're
saying but I see it kind of differently
and let me just explain why oh I'm a
racist great